voici venir le temps des vacances les
Français longtemps casanier sont de plus
en plus nombreux à rêver d'autres
horizons d'autres cultures plus de 25%
partent désormais à l'étranger nous
avons mis le cap avec eux vers le Maroc
pour découvrir comment se comportent les
Français à l'étranger et comment les
regardent ceux qui les accueillent nous
sommes installés pendant quelques jours
dans un club de vacances à Marrakech
vous travaillez ici tous les deux depuis
combien de temps
que c'est depuis l'ouverture de l'hôtel
disons c'est en avril 91 nous plaisez
d'autres pays donc c'est vrai qu'il y a
un certain plaisir donc ils vont se
travail on est si on est toujours
heureux
gay
comment sont les Français en vacances
vous les voyez arriver dans quel état
est repartir que bon ce qui a le
changement pour commencer d'abord le
premier jour il vous répondent pas au
bonjour
c'est justement c'est censé ce genre là
qui m'intéressent parce que j'essaie
justement un peu de les approcher même
des fois à jour c'est vers qui on
ressent on ressent un peu une certaine
méfiance
ça c'est pour la pour les gens qui n'ont
pas je dirais qu'ils n'ont pas
l'habitude de enfin qui sont qui
arrivent à la première fois ils font la
première fois le Maroc oui donc ils
lisent le Maroc à travers certaines
bouches je suis aperçoit à travers
certaines journaux donc des fois ils ont
une mauvaise idée sur le sur les lieux
qui se manifeste comment c'est quels
sont les a priori qu'ils ont
que vu qu'il y a je sais pas tout le
monde est au courant des problèmes ce
qui se passe en Algérie ce qui se passe
en Egypte les intégrer donc c'est à dire
que là certaines personnes
et il croit que en venant au Maroc
peut-être qu'ils trouveront
des exemples pareil ce qu'ils entendent
ce qui le regardent à travers les médias
et tout alors systématiquement là il
faut qu'on soit prêt à ce genre de ce
genre de de des choses beaucoup
reviennent bien sûr la plupart la
plupart et la plupart ils reviennent
pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'ils disent quand
ils reviennent c'est que la plupart des
gens qui qui vient souvent au Maroc ce
sont les gens qui qui ont eu qui ont eu
comme ami un habitant c'est à dire que
ils ont vécu qu'ils ont été chez
l'habitant chez le Marocain ils ont
envie d'en ils ont ils ont passé
certaines un certain temps de chez lui
et il ressent que il y a pas il y a pas
quelque chose de superficiel ils se
disent non c'est pas ce que c'est à ça
cache ce sourire taire ça cache autre
chose
on n'est pas il faut il faut s'attendre
à tout
votre famille est venue ici
dans notre religion c'est les hommes qui
décident pas les femmes et alors vous
avez décidé qu'elle ne viendrait pas ici
parce que ma femme c'est une
pratiquante alors il peut il peut pas
visiter les hôtels comme ça vous pour
votre épouse c'est choquant de voir par
exemple des femmes au seins nuls le long
de la plat de la piscine pardon c'est le
problème des hommes pas des femmes ce
qu'il veut dire c'est les hommes qui qui
va lui donner la déranger de voir un peu
au maillot de bain et tout mais femme
entre elles non ça les dérange pas
d'être avec vous alors qu'il y a des
femmes nues
c'est peut-être ça aussi qui voudrait
pas la faire venir ici mais le temps un
client une clientèle par exemple le
droit parce que c'est une si tu ne
repère comme ça ou bien c'est une ça
dépend de la clientèle mais vous non et
pour votre femme non plus mais
alors comment vous faites pour pour
avoir vous cette rigueur et cette
pratique
musulmane à l'extérieur et ici vivre
cette villa à être confronté sans arrêt
des choses que vous ne voulez pas pour
vous-même ou pour votre épouse voilà ça
c'est une bonne question par exemple moi
je travaille je vois surtout dans le à
la piscine ici au bar je vois les les
par exemple les femmes et les gazelles
en train de les
soutien-gorge comme ça mais pour moi ça
change rien parce que même si je vois
comme ça mais
voilà la question d'habitude
je peux voir même je peux pas par
exemple partir de une clientèle même il
me parle comme ça je peux que le drap
comme ça ça c'est c'est pas d'accord si
vous suivez la religion comme comme vous
le dites à point donc tenir le bas vous
devez servir de l'alcool c'est
aussi une pointe qui est très
intéressante par exemple moi je fais mon
devoir par exemple je suis la prière
jusqu'à l'alcool c'est normal
mais si on parle par exemple c'est dans
dans notre religion islamique du coup
les gens par exemple un musulman il doit
pas servir l'alcool comme ça
c'est interdit oui et alors comment vous
faites dans votre tête pour régler ce
dilemme ah ça dépend c'est ça qui
voudrait pas que ça fasse
travailler au bar
comment je vois les clients comme ça
peut-être qu'il est jaloux comme ça même
j'aimais rien dans la tête ça c'est le
travail et qu'on dit dans notre dans le
courant qui dit Dieu c'est le par
exemple le travail c'est une
femme comment se comportent-elles quand
elles sont en groupe
les femmes en vacances
des fois des fois je dirais pas tout je
dirais pas toutes mais des fois il y a
des dames qui
ben c'est pas qui cherche de la
compagnie oui mais ça ça reste pas
direct ça reste pas direct bien sûr il
reste discrète il faut comprendre des
choses parce que
on a on se dit voilà ce que je cherche
non faut pas cesser tenter quand même
faut faire très raisonnable
ne vous résistez bien elles font
résister
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai je
dirais pas je dirais pas que des fois
moi aussi j'ai ma faiblesse mais
des fois je m'en vais des fois je trouve
un prétexte tout ça pour ne pas faut pas
trop s'approcher quand même des gens
parce que si des fois
moi donc vous risquez d'avoir des
problèmes avec après mais vous vous êtes
moins en contradiction quand même qu'à
ça pour moi la vie c'est vivre ma vie
avec un minimum de dégâts faut pas que
j'en abuse donc pour moi je vis ma vie
tout en pensant au Jugement Dernier donc
faut pas c'est vrai que des fois on fait
des folies on boit d'alcool on sort avec
en sorte avec des femmes et tout mais il
faut qu'on se marie une fois qu'on a
plus de responsabilités là il faut
serrer un peu parce que après je me dis
j'ai la foi en Dieu peut être là je fais
pas la prière mais peut-être ça
m'arrivera inch'Allah je ferai la prière
jusqu'à dire qu'en faisant ça je sens
que je ne contrarie pas trop avec la
religion quand même
vous êtes dans un compromis une
adaptation difficile
mais c'est bien
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]